[Musique]
ça se ressentait à la maison elle
n'était plus agressive elle se renfermer
et en même temps à se refermer sur
elle-même elle prétextait n'importe quoi
pour ne plus aller en course à soigner
qu'elle n'était pas bien et le fait
qu'elle en parle pas ça nous créé de
plus les bras croisés cette jeune
conseillère départementale du collège
mendès mme de sainte-marie témoigne sur
son expérience de vie c'est réglé c'est
j'ai réussi à parler avec ses élèves à
leur faire comprendre que ce qui fait
parce que je pense pas que il s'en rend
des comptes en fait c'est ça le pire
c'est qu'il le faisait mais il s'en
rendait pas compte qu'elle était pas
bien
en même temps j'ai mis un peu la
pression administrations parce que moi
en tant que conseillère départementale
c'est moi qui représente le collège donc
j'ai mis un peu la pression monstration
mes parents sont venus on a on a fait
bouger les choses et ça c'est réglé
insomnie dennis colère des pressions ont
le sentiment d'impasse le harcèlement
fait partie de la vie de nos jeunes
un enfant sur huit seraient touchées par
ce fléau sachant que 59 % des plus de 13
ans sont actifs sur facebook
raison pour laquelle le conseil
départemental des jeunes initiée cette
journée de débats avec ses partenaires
jean henric les jeunes retiennent que
doivent aider en fait qu'ils doivent pas
se moquer les gens il faut avoir un
esprit de tolérance et de respect
sourire je
et surtout respectons-nous les uns
qualifié ces actes faire comprendre que
c'est un délit et sensibiliser sur les
conséquences pour le harceler pour le
harceleur et pour les témoins voilà
l'enjeu de ce débat de société a fait
une réunion dé préparation pour choisir
cette action on a choisi aussi les
intervenants pour qu'ils puissent et
expliquer de façon pratique et ludique à
des conseils départementaux et à des
classes de cm2 le harcèlement nous
concerne tous dans mon collège il ya des
personnes qui se font harceler je sais
qu'il y en a qui sont complètement
déscolarisés dans ma classe même est
quelqu'un qui ne vient plus parce que il
subi du harcèlement est donc vraiment
c'est qu'on ne peut rien faire nous
enfin c'est très compliqué à parent
c'est de parler de leur parler à eux et
de parler aux personnes éventuellement
qui vont les harceler mais c'est ça
pourrait mener compliqué nous sommes
tous uniques
l'omniprésence des réseaux sociaux dans
notre vie crée du harcèlement 24 heures
sur 24
et même si les adultes qui encadrent nos
enfants sont de plus en plus sensible
est fort mais comment faire comprendre
que nous sommes tous responsables vous
êtes inscrits sur le réseau
lorsque vous avez publié vous avez
commencé à bâtir les jeunes participent
ils veulent montrer vrai vraiment qu'ils
sont là ils veulent ils sont à notre
écoute
mais ils veulent vraiment que on les
écoute aussi on doit c'est un vrai
échange un vrai partenariat programmes
menés jusque jusqu'à la fin quoi jusqu'à
ce qu'ils puissent je dirais voulait de
proposer dans tous les cas là ils ont
besoin de bons donneurs de leçon je
dirais mais et nous nous devons être à
leurs côtés pour les accompagner
quand les spots de la police nationale
ont été diffusées le silence fait place
à la parole à la révolte
ainsi avec un spot pédagogique chaque
conseiller départemental jeunes a
maintenant pour mission de libérer la
parole dans son collège
[Musique]